hello everybody I'm professor and white
from the Department of nuclear science
and engineering here at MIT this is the
first of four preparatory lectures for a
seminar a lecture in 2208 one
sustainable energy on AC circuits in
this first lecture what we're going to
go over are some of the fundamental
circuit elements that we use in AC
circuits and these are the energy
storage elements the capacitor the end
the inductor they're going to be really
useful later on when we talk about
energy storage and energy transmission
and AC power systems I want to make a
note that if anyone's really getting
interested about the circuits that we
discuss in these little sub lectures
today you can go back and sort of take
another class at MIT 2207 one which is
an introductory course on electronics as
all of the lecture notes here were
adapted from Professor Hutchinson's
notes for that course so now let's go
ahead and start here on our notes to the
pad of paper talking about our two
circuit storage elements so the first
one is our capacitor when you look at a
circuit diagram you're going to see that
a capacitor is drawn as two parallel
lines with the leads connecting top and
bottom what you'll also notice when you
see the capacitor in a circuit diagram
is that it's going to have a labeled
polarity so the top will be labeled with
a plus for positive and the minus will
be labeled with a minus for negative so
we're now going to bias the capacitor by
putting a voltage drop across the two
parallel plates so we denote that just
by writing a little V for a voltage drop
across them now to keep our polarities
consistent in our circuits we're also
going to draw the direction of the flow
of current which we denote by an arrow
flowing down from the positive to the
negative and we give this a variable I
so our capacitor is going to be storing
charge on these parallel plates as we
put a voltage drop across it so that
means we can now write down the
operational
equations for our capacitor so let's go
and write those down our operational
equations are that the voltage drop
across the capacitor is equal to the
stored charge which will note with Q
divided by the capacitance so V equals Q
divided by C now we can also write this
because charge is related to current we
can also write this operational equation
as voltage equals one over the
capacitance one over C multiplied by the
integral of the current with respect to
time we could of course reverse this
operational equation and relate the
current and voltage differently by
writing the current flowing through our
capacitor I is just equal to the time
derivative of the charge DQ DT by our
identity which is then equal to the
capacitance C times DV DT so now we can
also do it note the key element here
which is for our capacitor our stored
charge Q is equal to our capacitance
capital C times the voltage drop across
the capacitor so Q equals capital C
times our voltage so as an aside here if
you find yourself looking at a circuit
diagram as part of your work or part of
your research you might notice that
sometimes there's two different versions
of how a capacitor circuit element is
drawn so let's go now to the notes and
write a little aside about that just to
help you out as you might see these
sometimes in your future journeys and
circuits so these two different types of
the circuit elements that you see in the
diagrams are coming about because
there's two main types of capacitors the
first main type will be drawn just as we
have with two parallel lines with plus
or minus and when it's drawn like this
it does
matter which polarity you use when you
connect the capacitor in the circuit
diagram this is a bipolar or an
unpolarized capacitor but sometimes
you'll see the capacitor element drawn
with a curved line and one straight line
instead of instead of two straight lines
so that will look like so and in this
situation what this is telling you is
that this particular capacitor is
actually a polar capacitor so it is
typically an electrolytic capacitor and
it must be connected in the circuit with
a particular polarization so you have to
make sure that you connect the vertical
straight line to the positive and the
curved line to the negative polarity so
let's move away from that aside and move
to the next important reason we're
talking about capacitors in this lecture
on AC circuits so I'm just going to
change my notes now and move to the next
page I think I have to rip this off
right so I avoid the shadow sorry I just
like really pull this guy Wow okay there
we go so so why are we introducing
capacitors in this lecture on AC
circuits energy storage and transmission
well that's because capacitors are going
to play a role in our larger systems
because they can store energy in the
electric field and so this is this is
sort of the way we want to think about
this is let's just write this down let's
go to our notes and just write down this
important point
for our capacitors so what we're doing
is by charging our capacitor we're
delivering energy to the capacitor yep
you're going to hold for a minute